αλά λεφτά μέσα αλλά σίγουρα στο στο άθηλημα το δικό πουυ ξέρω και που υπηρατώ
δεν υπάρχει υπερίττωση είναι ζημιά σα σεκάθα ένα άλλο θέμα των τελευταίων ημερώ που πρόεδρος
της όμως πονδίας κληθεί κάτε πολλές φορές να το απαντήσεται τίγνεται με τον βζέγο θα
φορέςι αθέε φανέλα της εθνικής κύπρουν ένασταρτου έμπι τώρα ίνεστων υπιακόν πυρέως συζήτετει πολύ επιπίδησυρολίγκα
πρδύο χρόνια κοιταξετε ποιος δε θα ήθελε να έχει έτσι πεκταρα στη σύνθεση της ενθυνικής
τομάρας για να ξεκαθαρίσουμε και λίκον τα πράγματα νομες δεν κοέέχει ενηνηθεί ι έει μεγαλώσει
στην κύπρο άρα έχει κυπριακόνι διαβατήρια και παζε στις αγαδημίες του έπαιζε στο αποέλ οσαα
έχει κυπριακόν διαβατηριων έχει πουργάρικό διαβατήριω που είναι η οικογένι που προερχει διοκογένεια του ιγωνίς
του κταλιπα και έχει γελληνικόο ίδιος έχει κάνει την επηλογή όταν έπρεπε να κάνευνει την
επιλογή να γωνισεί στην εθνική βουργρίας για τους δικόιτου λόγους το σευόμαστε ναπόλιτα κι αγωνίζεται
μετα χρόματα ση εθνικής πουργαρίας αυτό των στάτι θυνήκή πουργαρίας αυτή τη στιγμή διαγωνίζεται και
αυτή στα παράθυρα των προκρματικών για το για να και διεκδική την παρουσί αντισει στόευρο
πάσκι τη δή φυλιάδες κστην οποία εμείς έχουμε εξασφαλισμένοι λόγω το τι είμαστε ναι εμείς
μαζί με τους αάλλους τρεις σνές έχουμε ν εξασφαλίσει και από το τελευταίο παράθυνο έχουν
περάσει και άλλες χώρες άρατο φευροάν είναι η τελευταί οι διαδύο αγώνες που θα κρίνουν
ουσιαστικά κιι θα συμμετέχουν τους ομίλους του βασμέναι και το μάρτιο θα γείναι και κληρώς
ρα αυτή τη στιγμή ωσάχια γωνίζεται με την εθνική βουργαρίας αν εξαρτείτωσανδεμπαίση όταν και φόσον
τελειώσει τις υποχρεώσεις του με την εθνική βουργαρίας α και ο ίδιος θέλει νανα το
συζητήσουμε